President Eisgruber I have the
honor to present to you for the degree
of Doctor of Fine Arts honoris causa
Robert Geddes a gifted architect and
teacher he practiced and taught
architecture as a social art engaged in
the design of the human environment as
the first Dean of Princeton School of
Architecture he heightened its eminence
and distinctiveness expanded its scope
broaden its curriculum and deepened its
connections with the humanities Social
Sciences and public affairs his
Princeton report for the American
Institute of Architects changed the
structure of architectural education in
the United States by galvanizing these
kinds of cross-disciplinary connections
his buildings expressed deep
understanding of the human experience
and the prodigious environmental
sensitivity they serve as artful lessons
in shaping the built environment
al-tohra Tata mejia Cora Torrey bassoon
Aversa Todd Esprit catonian Cisco Missa
tee ad gradum torus in our Tabas elegant
opus honora's causa admitto
you